[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
دبابات
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
لايران ويؤكد ان الحوار هو السبيل الامثل
لحل الخلافات
ايران تعتقله المانيا على خلفيه تصوير حقل
النفطي وباريس قلقه على فرنسي محتجز في
طهران
عناصرها بتهم جرائم اغتصاب
[موسيقى]
الروسي على ارسال دبابات تشالنجر الى كياف
شدد اطلانطن على انها ستستمر في دعم
اوكرانيا حتى تنتصر على روسيا في الحرب من
مقابل وفي خطوه فسرها الغد في اكثر من
زاويه تعتزم روسيا اقامه مراكز قياده
جديده قرب اوروبا كم منطقه
على الحدود مع فنلندا اضافه الى زياده عدد
قوات الجيش الروسي الى مليون ونصف مليون
جنتي وهو مفسره مسؤولون غربيون على انه
رساله واضحه من بوتن تمهيدا لاطاله امد
الصراع في اوكرانيا او حتى امكانيه توسعه
هذا الصراع نحو دول اخرى اوروبيه بحسب
مسؤوليه
[موسيقى]
دعاء النور مجموعتين من التسلح
الاستراتيجي والاقليمي للقوات المسلحه
وهما مقاطعه موسكو
العسكريتان فضلا عن فرق عمل قائمه بذاتها
في اراضي الكيانات الجديده للاتحاد الروسي
وذلك لتعزيز العنصر القتالي للبحريه
والقوه الفضائيه الجويه وقوه الصواريخ
الاستراتيجيه
كشفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ومحملاتهم بالصواريخ
نشرت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه مقطع مصوره
للتدريبات قوات البريه على الدبابات
البريطانيه
عبارات قريبا في اوكرانيا مع المقطع
المصور
بيطلع راجل
[موسيقى]
سيده الميدان ربما صاحبه القتال البري
تورت عن الحروب الحديثه مؤخرا لتعود اليوم
بثقالها خطط استراتيجيه اوكرانيه باتت
الدبابات لا تغيب عنها استعدادا لشني
عمليه حاسمه او حتى لصد عمليه بريه كبرى
قد تشنها روسيا في الربيع القادم واقع
عسكري جديد يغير اهتمامات اوكرانيا من حرب
السماء الى الارض من الطائرات بدون طيار
والحرب السبرانيه وغيرها مما تعرف من
الاسلحه المتطوره الى البر والدبابات
بعد الحديث عن المرحله الجديده من الصراع
العسكري في الربيع القادم استفاقت
اوكرانيا عما تبقى لها من دبابات قديمه
تحتاج الى صيانه وصيانتها بيد الروس فقط
ما دفع كياف لتطلق نداءات الى اوروبا
للمساعده
نداءات لبتها اولا فرنسا بتاكيد ارسال
دبابات خفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس 10 فيما
بريطانيا تعاهدت بتزويد اوكرانيا باربعه
عشره دبابه من طراز شالنجر كما ابدت
الولايات المتحده استعدادا بتزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات او مدرعات وحدها المانيا
لم تتحرك اتجاه تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات من
طراز لو بارد الالمانيه المتقدمه كما لم
تسمح لاي دوله اخرى بتقديم هذه الدبابات
لاوكرانيا وخاصه كندا و بولندا قاده الجيش
الاوكراني يضغطون للحصول على 300 دبابه
و600 مدرعه في لقلب الموازين عسكريه خاصه
في المناطق التي ضمتها روسيا لوغانس
ودونيتسك وجابوريجيا تتوفر الاسلحه ربما
قريبا لكن يبقى التحدي في مدى سرعه
استعداد الجيش الاوكراني وتدريبه لاستخدام
كل المعدات العسكريه الجديده
موسكو حذرت من الدعم الغربي الاخير
لاوكرانيا مؤكده ان اثره لن يكون سوا
اطاله امد معاناتك وشعبها في حرب بريه قد
تتسع مستقبلا غيداء سالم العربيه
ينضم الينا من لندن عبرس سكايب روبرت فوكس
الباحث في الشؤون العسكريه والامنيه صدرك
رابط عندما نتحدث عن حرب طويله الامد
للجانبين الغربي والروسي نتحدث عن رهانين
سابدا بريهان الروسي على تعب واستنزاف
اوكرانيا مع الوقت بالحرب وعدم قدرته مع
الوقت على تحقيق اي يعني مكسب استراتيجي
على الارض هل هذا الرهان الروسي سينجح
فائده
[موسيقى]
في هذه اللحظه لان هذا همم
المدفعيه والقنابل والدبابات قررت في
تقيمه الناس
صباح اليوم وانا روسيا خسرت 1600 دبابه
خلال النزاع الى الان وهذا عدد كبير
كما هم بحاجه الى المزيد من القوات وهنا
لك التكهنات كثيره
حول التغيير
ربما سيكون هناك جديد اخر ف- بشكل
اعتمد عشر شهرا همم
اوكرانيا وكما كنت من دون اي نتائج واضحه
ومن دون الخروج من هذا الوضع العالق على
الاقل
على اربعه او خمسه
اوكرانيا وهذا سيكون طالب كبير ولا سبت
انه اوكرانيا طالب
همم
يرغبون بتعزيزات جويه تكون مشكله كبيره
ولكن ان يعقد اجتماعات كثيره هذا الاسبوع
وهمم
[موسيقى]
دون اللي ارسال ذخيره كثيرا لاوكرانيا
لانه يعتبر ان الخسائر على الارض الخسائر
او العقوبات الاقتصاديه مزيد من التضييق
ايضا في الفتره المقبله ممكن ان ينهك
الاله الاقتصاديه والماليه والحربيه
الروسيه ويمنعها من الاكمال على المدى
البعيد هل سينجح هذا التكتيك او الريحان
بيبي
بمثابه التمني من العواصم الغربيه وغيرها
لان ما شهدناهم
خلال الايام القليله او الاسابيع الماضيه
هو انا بوتن غير ذلك من عمليه عسكريه خاصه
الى حرب روسيه داخل اوكرانيه من اجل نجاتي
نسخته الخاصه من روسيا والتي ارى بانها
مهددهم هذا هو رهانه
سترهقه اوكرانيا والى الان لم يتحقق ذلك
وتسببت بها اضرار كبيره جدا
هذه الجرائم الحرب عليه همم ان يقدم قوه
اكبر بكثير من كافه الانواع وهذا بالتالي
سيؤثر على الاقتصاد الروسي وعلى رغم كل
شيء نجح الى حد ما ولكنه يتراجع
ال- ال- الاقتصاد الموازي لاسبانيا او حتى
دوله اصغر لم تعد روسيا باللاعب الاقتصاد
الكبير
القوى الكبرى وبدات مظاهرها عبر اعلان
بالتمركز على حدود اوروبا هل يعد طرفين
خطوره حرب طويله الامل باختصار لو سمحت
كاملين
معلومات
كانت مؤثره وفعاله لانها جزء من النص
الشمالي للكره الارضيه والديمقراطيات
اوروبا اوروبا
والخليج فهي فعاله جدا
[موسيقى]
روسيا مهمه بالتاكيد لمصادر الطاقه العالم
ولكن اكبر امر مجهول حاليا هو الصين هنالك
بوادر منا بكين تحت جيد اكتفت جدا بهذا
الاسم
وخاصه ما يحصله يا رب المهمه جدا لتجارتها
ونطرتها لنفسها في العالم ومركزها ويبدو
بان هذا
اختلاط كبيره جدا كل العواصم العالميه يجب
ان تصغي الى بكين
[موسيقى]
شكرا
قالت شبكه سي ان الامريكيه الى الحرب في
اوكرانيا قدمت للولايات المتحده وحلفائها
فرصه نادره لدراسه كيفيه اداء انظمه مؤكده
انا اوكرانيا تحولت لمختبر كبير ذخائر
والاسلحه الغربيه ولمعرفه ماذا
يعني ان اوضحت ان مسيرات سويتش بليد
والصاروخ المصمم لاستهداف انظمه
تبين انها اقل فاعليه مبرزه ان قاذفه
الصواريخ المتعدده ام 1 فورت الامريكيه
خفيفه الوزن او هيمارس كانت حاسمه لنشرح
اوكرانيا واشارت الشبكه الامريكيه الا ان
الامريكيين تاكد
براميلتها عند اطلاق الكثير من القذائه في
فتره زمنيه قصيره وظيفه ان القاده
او ام 7 7 من الصعب تحريكها بسرعه لتجنب
اكدت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه على
استمرار الدعم والمساعدات الى اوكرانيا
لاستعاده الطاقه والمياه وتحضر لجهود
الاعمار
ى دعمنا الثابت لاوكرانيا وتقديم
المساعدات لاستعاده الطاقه والتدفئه
والمياه بالاضافه الى التحضير لجهود اعاده
الاعمار على المدى الطويل المفوضيه ستقدم
ثلاثه مليارات يورو كدفعه اولى من حزمه
الدعم المالي الذي تبلغ قيمته 18 مليارا
للعام الحالي وهي اكبر مساعده ماليه على
الاطلاق لدوله ثالثه
[موسيقى]
اشار وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان خلال مؤتمر دافوس على ان المملكه
تواصلت مع ايران لمحاوله البحث عن طريق
للحوار
مع جيراننا لان المؤمن بشده بان الحوار هو
السبيل الامثل لحل الخلافه نشعر بقوه بان
ما قمنا به في المملكه وما يقوم به اخرون
في المنطقه خاصه دون مجلس التعاون الخليجي
لمعالجه تحديات اقتصاداتهم والاستثمار
وليس على المسائل الجيو السياسيه كانت
علامه قويه لايران واخرين في المنطقه بان
هناك مسار بعيدا عن الجدالات والنزاعات
القديمه تجاه الازدهار المشترك كل ما
تمكننا من التعاون في المنطقه كل ما عملنا
ما عنه وحققنا ازدهار ليس فقط لشعبنا بل
لمن طاقتنا وخارجي
الاميره فيصل بن فرحان و خلال مؤتمردافوس
قال ان السعوديه تهتم بامن الطاقه
واستقرارها مشيدا بسياسه اوبك بلس
طاقه عمل الاساسيه
تحديات كبيره جدا وارتفاعه نحن ملتزمون
بما يتعلق بذلك وايضا ملتزمون بمستقبل
الطاقه النظيفه
بدوره وخلال مداخله في منتدى دافوس عبر
عضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه السنافر
للحفاظ على استقرار سوق الطاقه مشيرا الى
ان المخاوف اتجاه هذه القرارات تبددت مع
مرور الوقت وان رؤيه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اثبتت صحتها
لكن مع مرور الوقت اتفقنا مع رؤيه المملكه
وصاحب السمو ومع اجراء المزيد من الحوارات
ادركنا ان هناك مسار ايجابيا لتعزيز
العلاقات
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بمشاركه النساء ثلاث منظمات غير حكوميه
تستانف نشاطها بشكل جزئي في افغانستان
[موسيقى]
مواطنا المانيا في محافظه
جنوب البلاد بزريعه تصويره اماكن حساسه في
المحافظه اي السلطات الايرانيه ان المواطن
الالماني جرى اعتقاله عند اعتقاده صورا
لاماكن حساسه لمنشات مدينه العميديه
النفطيه وفي ذات الوقت ضاعت وزاره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه الى الافراج الفوريه عن
مواطنها
المحتجز في ايران منذ اكتوبر العام الماضي
معرفه عن قلقها بشان صحه ومصيره
[موسيقى]
تراجع الاحتجاجات السياسيه في ايران
لتتقدم الاحتجاجات المطلبيه بعد ما دخلت
البلاد في موجه برد وسقيع غير مسبوقه خلال
العقود الماضيه لليوم الرابع على التوالي
الاحتجاجات مستمره في محافظه خرسان رضوي
بعد انقطاع الغاز رغم تساقط الثلوج
وانخفاض الحراره الى ما دون الصفر وذلك في
بلد يمتلك ثاني اكبر مخزون نصف العالم من
بعد روسيا اما في الاهواز التي تضم ثمانين
بالمئه من النفط الايراني فاحتج عمال
وموظفي الصناعات النقل على انخفاض روابط
رواتبهم في الوقت الذي تعاني فيه البلاد
من ازمه اقتصاديه خانقه وصل فيها التضخم
الى ثمانيه همم 40% ومن اجل حل ازمه الغاز
لجا النظام الايراني الى التقليل
الاستهلاك الغاز باغلاق المدارس والدوائر
في طهران وبعض المدن الاخرى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ما يحصل الان هو بالضبط ما اراده النظام
الايراني ان يحصل في الفتره الماضيه وهو
تحول في مسار الاحتجاجات في البلاد التي
بدات تمديدا بمقتل مهسا امين وبمطالبات
بتغيير رموز النظام واسقطه اما الان فقد
انحصرت المطالب وباتت تتركز اكثر على كل
ما يتعلق الاقتصاد والمعيشه اضافه الى
انخفاض وتيره الاحتجاجات وتقلصها نوعا ما
دوريا مشاهدينا طلبه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
كل العالم بضروره الرد على انتهاكات ايران
لحقوق الانسان وفرض عقوبات ضد النظام
الايراني المتهم بانتهاك المبادئ الاساسيه
لحقوق الانسان وتصنيف الحارس الثوري
الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه
[موسيقى]
شوارع دينك
وهو فرنسي
وفي الملف الايراني ايضا اشارت صحيفه
تايمز الى ان النظام في طهران يفضل ان تتم
مهاجمه المرشد خامنئي عوضا عن مهاجمه
الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي كي لا تضطر الحكومه
لتقديم تنازلات وقالت الصحيفه ان ابراهيم
رئيسي يتجنب اللوم لان القوه المؤيده
للديمقراطيه في ايران توجه الغضب الى مكان
اخر فن نتابع
المتظاهرون في ايران ومعهم بعض الاصلاحين
غضبهم على المرشد منذ دلاع الاحتجاجات في
الشارع الايراني
لكنهم تجنبوا الرئيس الايراني استثناء
رئيسي لم يغضب النظام بل على العكس من ذلك
بحسب صحيفه
الابتعاد عن مهاجمه رئيسي يعني عدم مهاجمه
الحكومه وبالتالي فهي لن تكون مضطره الى
تقديم تنازلات بحسب الصحيفه التي رات ان
ابتعاد الرئيس الايراني عن الواجهه يناسب
القياده الايرانيه حتى وان صبغ غضب
المحتجين على منه صحيفه كيهان التابعه
لمرشد ايران اقرت بسخط المتظاهرين على
خامنه مشيره الى ان المحتاجين لم يهتفوا
بشعارات ضد اي سياسي اخر
اقرار فسره البعض بانه محاوله من خامنئي
للافاده من ذلك في تقويه سلطته من خلال
اقناع السياسيين بانه راس الحربه في
الدفاع عن النظام
ومع اتساع غضب الشارع الايراني على النظام
ورموزه يوما بعد يوم يحاول النظام بكل
الطرق ايجاد مخرج باستخدام القوه او
بغيرها لايقاف مد هذه التظاهرات المستمر
[موسيقى]
لاين
ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني على قائمه
المنظمات الارهابيه
دي اكشن
ان تصرفات النظام الايراني فظيعه ومروعه
وهم يدوسون على حقوق الانسان الاساسيه
باقدامهم لذا فانما نراه امر لا يصدق وما
يحدث في ايران يحتاج الى رساله قويه جدا
ورد فعل قوي جدا بالتالي فاننا نتطلع
بالفعل الى جوله جديده من العقوبات وساؤيد
ايضا ادراج الحرس الثوري في القائمه لقد
سمعت عده وزراء يطلبون ذلك واعتقد انهم
على حق
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من امستردام مع
بروسكايب فؤاد عطيه الباحث في شان
الايراني استاذ فؤاد يعني ما يحصل اليوم
من تغير بمصار التظاهرات من سياسيه
تغييريه للنظام رافضه لكل النظام الى
اجتماعيه بحث هل مرد الى الازمه
الاقتصاديه التي تتساقم وتضييق الخناق
الذي يعتمده النظام بالشارع الايراني ام
ايضا الى سياسه الاعدام والقتل التي
رهبت الجيل الجديد والنساء الذين كانوا
يشكلون عصب هذه التظاهرات ام الاثنين معا
لا هي دائما الاحتجاجات بايران كانت لها
وجهين وجه معيشي وجه سياسي ولكن بطبيعه
طبيعه النظام الشمولي داخل ايران
يجعل اي مطلب احتجاجه هو سياسي بشكل بديهي
يعني اي مطلب ايران هو سياسي ان كان معي
شيء او ان كان حقوقي بعد ولكن المطالب
الاخيره حتى يعني الاحتجاجات الاخيره او
المسار الثوري حتى الغالبيه الايرانيين
يسمونه
الحراك والثوره وليس مجرده احتجاجات
المسار الحديث هو المسار الثور الجديد هو
همم مختلف وهو بدا يمكن بمرحله جديده يعني
قد يكون نجاح النظام بقمعه باساليبه
التقليديه الوحشيه عبر الاعدامات والقتل
قتل المظاهرين او استهدافهم او ترهيب
ترهيب همم
النشطاء بالخارج ولكن نرى هناك ملامح
لتصعيد جديد شعبي مثلا نرى هناك استهداف
لمقرات للحرس في مناطق جديده بايران داخل
طهران بمشهد هذه المناطق هاي هاي اول هذه
اول مره بتاريخ يمكن خلال 40 سنه من بعد
الثوره الايرانيه هناك استهداف
لقواعد الحرس الثوري عسكريا او استهدافهم
سابقا كانت هذه الاستهدافات مقصوره بمناطق
مثل بلوجستان او كردستان او مناطق بعيده
فهذا التصعيد يدل على انه شعبيا او او
المسار الثوره لم يتوقف قد يتصل بشكل جديد
ولكنه ولكنه مستمر
الثورات او التغيير هو طويل لياخذ عشرات
السنين ويعني الايراني بدا بمراكمه همم
يعني اضعاف النظام عبر مسارات مختلفه
وعبرهازات مختلفه منذ سنوات هل يمكن القول
ان ما حصل هذه المره هو الاكثر تعليما
بجسد النظام والاتي من بعده سيكون اقوى
بكثير
انه توقف ولكن الفاصل او النقطه او او
تغيير الاساس الذي حدث باعتقاد انه
المنطقه الرمادي او النسبه الكبيره من
السكان يعني غير سياسي غير مهتمين
بالسياسه
الرماديه من السكان هذه كانت غير غير يعني
لا تبالي بالمطالب السياسيه هذه النسبه من
السكان الان دخلت في الحراك الثوري بسبب
الوضع المعيشي الذي يفرض عليهم
ايجاد حل للوطن معي شيء حتى وان كانوا غير
سياسي فهذا الترابط بين
النسبه الكبيره من السكان او الشعب
الايراني مع المطالب اللي همم السياسيين
او المعارضه بالخارج هذا الجديد يعني
الثوره الجديده لهذا نرى حتى بالخارج مثلا
المباراه التي تقام همم
مؤخرا او بالمانيا هناك ترى مثلا نسبه
كبيره من الايرانيين اللاجئين خارج همم
خارج ايران ينضموا لهذا لانه
لانه يروا انه الفرق قد تكون الاخيره
لاسقاط هذا النظام
الحراك مستمر اساليب جديده وقد يكون هناك
همم الحراك الدولي مثلا بتصنيف الحرس
الثوري منظمه ارهابيه قد تكون هي بدايه
حقيقي دولي يساعد للاحتجاجات الداخليه
اشياء اخذ مراحل عده ولم ياتي على مرحله
واحده وبتالي نحن نتحدث عن مرحله طويله
شكرا لك استاذ فؤاد عطيه البحث في شان
الايراني حدثنا من امستردام
ذكر او وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير
عبد الحيان خلال مؤتمر الصحفي مشترك مع
وزير الخارجيه تركيه انا الاتفاق النووي
من الممكن ان يحدث اذا قامت امريكا بعمل
خطوات اللازمه على حد قوله
اذا تركت امريكا تصريحاتها المتناقضه
وقامت بالخطوات اللازمه لتحقيق الاتفاق
النووي فان هذا الاتفاق من الممكن ان يحدث
لشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
لا حل في سوريا دون مشاركه ايران فيها هذا
ما اعلنت عنه الخارجيه الايرانيه مؤخرا
تصريحا يبدو وكانه رساله للنظام الاسد
الذي يخوض مفاوضات اعاده التطبيع مع تركيا
دون اشراك او تواجد ايران طرفا فيها
الامتعاض الايراني انصح القول من الاسد
كان قد ظهر قبل يومين عندما ابلغ الطهران
دمشق بان النفط الايرانيه المرسل لسوريا
لن يكون مجانا بعد الان قهران كشفت عن دور
لها في التفاوض بين النظام والاكراد في
سوريا وهو ما يعني دورا منفردا في الملف
السوري تزامنا مع المفاوضات بين انقره
ودمشق برعايته
[موسيقى]
هذا هو خلال زيارته لانقره وفي مؤتمر
الصحفي مع نظيره الترك
الهجمات والجماعات الارهابيه التي تاتي
عبر الحدود السوريه التركيه
ده الاندرويد
التي استمرت 11 عاما تشكلت فرصه لا تفوت
بالنسبه للجماعات الارهابيه وموقفنا واضح
وثابت تجاه هذه الجماعات التي تاتي الينا
عن طريق الحدود السوريه ولذلك يجب علينا
التكاثف لتنظيف هذه المنطقه من الارهاب
هشام رئيس لجنه القانونيه او هشام مروه
رئيس اللجنه القانونيه في الائتلاف الوطني
السوري اهلا بك دكتور هشام يعني بالفتره
الماضيه كان الرهان الاساسي النظام الاسد
هو اللاعب على التناقضات الايرانيه
الروسيه داخل سوريا اليوم اللعب على هذه
التناقضات وصفه مطالبه الطرفين بموقف حاسم
ببعض الملفات والرفض الايراني على عدم
يعني همم ان يكون هناك اي حل خارج المسار
الايراني هل يمكن ان يكمل به الاسد وما
ماذا سيفعل بالمرحله المقبله
مساء الخير لكل الاخوه المشاهدين الواقع
يعني زياده رئيسي اذا دمشق وزياره عبد
الله عن ثم هذا النشاط ما بين دمشق طهران
انقره يؤكد تماما وخصوصا مع تاجيل الاتصال
اللقاءات التي كانوا متوقع ان تعقد في
منتصف هذا الشهر
بياكد ان الدور الايراني دخل ليفرمل علاقه
همم
تركيا والروس من جهه من اجل التطبيع مع
نظام الاسد بين الاسد وبين همم الاتراك
هذا الامر هذا الامر بالذات هو يعني يؤكد
ان الايرانيين اللاعب الرئيسي بالنسبه لا
يمكن ان يتخلى عنهم لا شك ان هناك همم
العلاقات السوريه الايرانيه بسبب همم ازمه
النقض في سوريا وازمه توريد النقطه التي
يعني الان الايرانيون يريدون ان يتقاضوا
ن- مقدما وهذا امر لم يكن فارغا حتى ايام
الاسد الكبير يعني نحن امام نشهد الحقيقه
معقده المشهد ان يقوم على اساس ايران لن
تسمح باي تقارب ترعاه روسيا بين تركيا
وروسيا الا ان تكون وفق تطلعاتها ووجودها
في همم في سوريا وهذا امر للاسف الاسد غير
قادر ان يخرج من هذا من هذه
الكماشه صح التعبير وهوضع مواجهه الاسد
بحاجه لايران وايران ايضا لا تستطيع
الخروج من سوريا حتى وان راى ببعض الملفات
لما تمثله سوريا من اهميه استراتيجيه
بالنسبه للايراني كما هو معلوم يعني وصل
الهلال الشيعي الوصول الى المتوسط وكل
ملفات الاخرى وبالتالي الوجود استراتيجي
هناك وسط هذه الاهميه استراتيجيه للملف
السوري كيف سيتعاطى الايراني يعني بحذر
باللعب على على تناقضات الموجوده هناك
الاسد يعني جعل وجوده وقرار الاسد مرتبط
به مرتضى لقرار الاسد مرت- حمايه الاسد
ايرانيه
السيطره على الاقتصاد في سوريا بشكل كبير
جدا ايرانيه ولذلك الاسد مكبل في العلاقه
مع ايران وهو للاسف يعني للاسف ان تصل
سوريا الى هذه الحاله لكن هذا هو الواقع
الاسد الواقع غير قادر على الخلاص من هذا
الشرك الموضوع فيه ايرانيه وهو بالتالي
سيؤثر هذا على مستقر علاقاته سواء كان مع
تركيا او مع غيرها بالنسبه للرؤوس تلاعب
رئيسي في المنطقه وخصوصا في هذه الازمه
الاخيره علاقتها مع الحرب الاخرانيه حديثه
على ان يكون لها وجود في الدافئه بالتاكيد
هذه الوجود لن يسر لن يكون الا كما
يتوافق مع المصالح ايراني وهو امر لا ترضى
به روسيا ولا تقبل به تركيا محاوله اخراج
سوريا من التاثير الايراني الحقيقه ام
المهم جدا لاستقرار المنطقه وجود ايران في
المنطقه وجود ايران في سوريا للاسف الشديد
هو عنصر توتر يهدد الامن والسلم
الاقليميين والعمل على اخراج من سوريا هي
مقدم للحل السياسي الذي تطلع عليه
السوريون لا حل سياسي ولذلك يعني كان كلام
همم الوزير التركي واضح جدا بالنص على
اهميه ان يكون هناك همم يعني همم على
تطبيق لقرارات الامم المتحده المتعلقه
بمشكله الحل السياسي في سوريا وعوده
اللاجئين ووقفي عمليات الحديثه
[موسيقى]
في افغانستان بشكل
ثلاث منظمات غير حكوميه نشاطها في
افغانستان بشكل جزئي لمشاركه موظفات بعد
تلقي ضمانات من حكومه طالبان لان النساء
يمكننهن مواصلات العمل في قطاع الصحه
وشاملت عوده النساء الافغانيات للعمل في
عده منظمات غير حكوميه بين لجنه الانقاذ
الدوليه وانقذوا الاطفال وكائر ما سهل
عوده عمل منظمات وتقديم مساعدات في قطاعين
الصحه والغذاء في عدد من المناطق وتقدم
المنظمات غير الحكوميه مساعدات اساسيه
لنصف سكان افغانستان البالغ عددهم 38
مليون نسمه لمواجهه انعدام الامن الغذائيه
الحاد
[موسيقى]
في افغانستان ايضا توفي اربعه اطفال واكثر
من 35 شخصا في جراء موجه البرد وحركه
طالبان تقف مكبله الايدي الازمه الانسانيه
المزيد في التقرير التاليه
حركه طالب
الاطفال
خلال الايام الماضيه بينهم اربعه اطفال في
ولايه
لموجه البرد القارس التي تجتاح ارجاء
افغانستان
انخفاض درجات الحراره بشكل كبير وتساقط
الامطار والثلوج وفق توقعاته هيئه الارصاد
يتبع لطالبا
ما قد يحول دون وصول المساعدات والمنظمات
الاغاثيه للمحتاجين حسب مكتب الامم
المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه في
افغانستان اضافه الى عراقيل عده تقول
المنظمه ان قوانين حركه طالبان احد اهم
مسبباتها
تاثر بسبب حظر طالبان عمل النساء في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه والنتيجه لمواد غير
الصالحه للتدفئه التي يستخدمها معظم
الافغان بسبب الفقر توفي عده اشخاص نتيجه
اختناقهم بالمواد المحروقه والغاز
باغلاق الوصول الى المناطق النائيه في
افغانستان حيث يوجد بالفعل نقص في الادويه
والمواد الغذائيه وقد تضررت الافتارات من
المحاصيل الشتويه بشده امام وقوف حكومه
حركه طالبان عاجزه عن التعامل مع الموقف
ماديا ولوجستيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في لبنان وفد قضائي
اوروبي ووثائق تحويلات مصرفيه لها علاقه
بتحقيق يتعلق بمعرفه ما اذا كان حاكم مصرف
لبنان وشقيقه يختلفا اموالا عامه ويستكمل
الوفد القضائي الاوروبي وسط تحركات
للمذيعين الامين بمحاسبه احد المسؤولين عن
خساره اموالهم
من صرخات الموضعين شق الورد القضاء
الاوروبي طريقه الى قصر العدل
يوم جديد من الاستجوابات يخضع لها نواب
السابقون لحاكم مصرف لبنان ومديرون عمون
لمصاريف كانت شاهده على تحويل مبالغ ضخمه
وصلت الى نصف مليار دولار اموال تعود
لرياض سلامه الحاكم الذي ثمنه اللبنانيون
على ارزاقهم فخسرها فيما تمكنه هو عبر
شركه يملكها شقيقه من تحويل الملايين الى
الخارج
بالرغم من وجود الالف الدعوه بحق اصحاب
المصارف ولا مره استدعى صاحب مصرف لها
السبب ان احنا مع اي تحرك او نشاط ممكن
يؤدي للكشف عن مصيرنا خمسه مصاريف
لائحه المطوله من الاسئله
في تلك المصارف وان لم تكن متورطه لكنها
كانت شاهده على عمليات تحويل التي جعلت من
سليم مشتبهان به في تهم تبيض اموال
اما القضاء اللبناني فلم يحرك ساكنا ولم
يتعاون مع القضاء الاوروبي في قضايا فساد
وقعت ضمن اراضيه للتاخذ الدول الاوروبيه
على عاتقها مهمه التوجه الى لبنان
واذا ابقى قضاء لبنان على دوره كمتفرج لن
يتمكن اللبنانيون من استرداد اموالهم
الموهوبه في حال وضعت الدول الاوروبيه
يدها على اموال سلامه
الهدف الاول الاستعداد لهذه المرحله
لاسترداد ما سيتم الاستلاء عليه والحجز
عليه في هذه الدول الاوروبيه والهدف
الثاني استغلال ما يحصل الان في حال اقدم
المحقق الاوروبي على افاده القضاء
وبالتالي اصدار الادانات والاحكام ان
يستفيد القضاء اللبناني والسلطات
اللبنانيه من هذه الاحكام للتوسع في
عمليات التحقيق
هذا واعلن المرصد الاوروبي للنزاهه ان
القضاء اللبناني محكوم بالتدخلات السياسيه
منذ ثلاثين عاما اما عمل الوفد الاوروبي
فسيبرهن ان لا احد فوق القانون
يعملوا اللبنانيون ان يتخذ القضاء
الاوروبي اجراءات عجز عنها القضاء
اللبناني فالمواطنين بانتظار محاسبه من
اساء اليهم باي طريقه ممكنه غنوه يتيم
العربيه بيروت
[موسيقى]
الصين ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم تواجه
رياحا معاكسه مع نهايه عام 2022 حيث وصل
النمو في البلاد الى ادنى مستوياته في وقت
تراجع فيه عدد السكان للمره الاولى منذ
نحو سته عقود في تفاصيل الارقام حقق
الاقتصاد الصيني نموا بنسبه ثلاثه بالمئه
في عام 2022 وفقه المكتب الوطني للاحصاء
مسجلا ادنى معدلاته خلال 40 عاما بسبب
تفشي فيروس كورونا والازمه العقاريه التي
شهدتها البلاد تمثل هذه الارقام اسوا نمو
الصين منذ عام
1976 وكان لمشاكل الصين الاقتصاديه العام
الماضي ارتدادات انعكست على سلاسل التوريد
العالميه التي لا تعاني تزال تعاني منها
حاليا مع تراجع الطلب مشاهدينا نتوقع على
البنك الدولي ان ينتعش الانتاج والناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للصين الى
4.3% عام 20
20 لكنه رغم ذلك لا يزال اقل من التوقعات
الاقتصاديه على صعيد اخر تراجع عدد سكان
الصين خلال العام الماضي للمره الاولى منذ
نحو سته عقود حيث تلوح في الافق ازمه
ديموغرافيه تهدد اكبر دوله في العالم من
ناحيه عدد السكان هذا وشهدت الدوله التي
يبلغ عدد سكانها واحد فصل 4 مليار نسمه
انخفاضا في معدل الولادات الى مستويات
قياسيه ترافق مع تقدم قوتها العامله في
العمر الصين مشاهدينا انهت 1000 عام 2016
سياسه الطفل الواحد التي فرضتها في
الثمانيات بسبب مخاوفه من زياده سكانيه
هائله وعام 2021 بدات بالسماح للازواج
بانجاب ثلاثه اطفال
[موسيقى]
صدمه كبيره في بريطانيا خلفها اعتراف ضابط
شرطه انجليزي
24 عمليه اغتصاب وعددا من الاعتداءات
الجنسيه خلال 24 عاما من مده خدمته وهو ما
وصفته النيابه العامه البريطانيه بانه من
اكثر القضايا اثاره للصدمه بين تلك
المتعلقه بواحد من عناصر الشرطه وهو ما
عرض هذا الجهاز الامني في لندن تحديدا
لانتقادات حاده من الاوساط الصحفيه
والسياسيه والعامه في المملكه المتحده
الامر الذي دفع بالشرطه لندن الى اعاده
فتح ملفات قديمه متمثله في اعاده مراجعه
1633 حاله اعتداء جنسيه او عنف مزعومه همم
بها اكثر من 1000 عنصر في الشرطه
[موسيقى]
مره اخرى تكشف الشرطه لندن عن المجرمين في
صفوفها ويرتدي زيها وتعترف بانها اتجاهل
التحذيرات ارتكابه الجرائم
لقد خدنا لندن
بسيط حقا وشجاعه الابلاغ عنه امر مثير
للاعجاب
ضابط الشرطه لمده 18 عاما النساء
المستضعفات وارتكب جرائم بحقهن واعترف كرك
امام المحكمه ب 94 منها 24 حاله اغتصاب
طالت اثنا عشر سيده ضحاياه شعارنا بانه لا
يمكننهن التقدم بشكوى ضد في وقت مبكر لانه
قال لهن لا احد سيصدقهن هذه الفضيحه شوهت
سمعه الشرطه
بهذه الجرائم كيف يمكن النساء بالشرطه
ليس لدي اي ثقه في جهاز الشرطه خصوصا وان
شرطيا حاولت تقرب مني بهذه الطريقه عندما
كنت في شبابي
فضيحه الشرطه ارغمت الداخليه على تقديم
احاطه الى النواب
البرلمان ان الحكومه لن تخجل من تحدي
الشرطه للوفاء بالمعايير التي نتوقعها
جميعا التغيير يجب ان يحدث وبصفه وزيره
الداخليه سافعل كل ما في وسعي لضمان ذلك
بانتظار يصطاد حكم مدته سجنه طردت من
الشرطه التي تعرضت للكثير من الانتقادات
لسلوك عناصرها في السنوات الاخيره اطاحت
برئيستها السابقه هذا الضابط المدن ليس
الاول الذي ارتكب جرائمه وهو يعمل في جهاز
الشرطه ولن يكون الاخير مع تاكيد رئيس
مفوضيه شرطه العاصمه ان هناك العشرات من
اعضائه يخضعون للتحقيق بشان ما زعم سوء
سلوك الجنسي او العنصريه مصطفى زاروه
العربيه لندن
وايضا يكمل معنا مصطفى زار مراسل العربيه
من لندن مصطفى يعني ما هي تبعات هذه
القضيه على الشرطه البريطانيه وكيف يمكن
ان يكون هناك ردود فعل اكثر سياسيه على
هذا الموضوع
من دون الشك بان ردود افعال اساسه سيستمر
على خلفيه هذه الفضائح ويجيب تذكير بان
هذه الفضائح هي تمتد لي عقدين من الزمن
همم يعني تقريبا في 20 سنه الماضيه وايضا
تقوم وزاره الداخليه الان
متابعه همم شؤون الشرطه عن قرب وتقول بان
يجب ان تتغير هذا بالاضافه الى ان همم
يعني بسبب انتكاسات التي شهدناها في في
السنوات القليله الماضيه من همم من يعني
استقاله همم الرئيس
كرسيدا ديك بسبب الاهملات وايضا الاخفاءات
عناصرها وخاصه فيما يتعلق بخطف وقتل سيدتي
في الثالثه والثلاثين من العمر قبل عامين
من الان كان وراءها ضابط شرطه يعمل لحمايه
البعثات الديبلو بالاضافه الى بعض همم
التصرفات غير الاخلاقيه والسلوك غير يعني
المشين الذي شهده عدد من هذه العناصر يجب
التذكير بان همم
الرئيس او قائد شرطه اسكتلنديات الجديد
الذي تمتعينه في الصيف الماضي كان على
خلفيه محاوله يعني همم اعاده سمعه هذه
الشرطه التي التي بها تقريبا ما يقارب من
43,000 عنصر الشرطه وقال بان لربما هناك
المزيد من الضباط السيئين وايضا موظفين
داخل هذا الجهاز وهذا يعني بان اضرب ربما
سيتم همم التخلص من هؤلاء الضباط السيئين
الذين اساءوا الى الوظيفه في خدمه حمايه
الناس بالاضافه الى اولئك لا دينيه يعملون
في المكاتب التابعه للشرطه وهذا ربما
سيتطلب بعض الوقت ولكن قال ربما هناك ربما
المئات يعني لا انا ذكرت العشرات
ولكن قال بانه ربما هناك ما يقارب من 800
ضابط وموظف الشرطه يتم مراجعه ادعاءات
بسلوك غير اخلاقي بالاضافه الى العنف
المنزلي كل هذه يتم مراجعتها وتم اضافه
المزيد من
المحققين في الشرطه لمحاوله حسم هذا الملف
الذي فعلا اساء الى هذه المنظمه همم يعني
همم يعني الضخمه وهي اكبر قوه شرطه في
البلد
هل نتحدث عن اجراءات عقابيه قانونيه فقط
ام عن اجراءات هيكليه جذريه داخل همم هذا
همم يعني همم الجهاز الذي يعتبر كما ذكرت
من الاجهزه الاساسيه داخل البلد
من دون الشك ان التغيير بدا منذ التعيين
قائد الشرطه جديد سير مارك رولي الذي تحدث
في التقرير وهو له خلفيه كبيره كان يقود
شرطه مكافحه الارهاب وربما يريد ان يعيد
هذه السمعه الى هذه المنظمه الامنيه همم
قال بان هناك 1,000 1,000 اكتر من 1600
حادثه
يتمراجعتها حاليا قد تكون بعضها انذار
خاطئ ولكن هناك هناك يعني ثبوتات الان يجب
التحقيق في هذه المزاعملها وبالتالي كل من
ثبت انه يعني خلق القانون يجب معاقبته ومن
ثم شهيدنا بهذا الضابط همم الذي اعترف
بارتكاب بتسعه او 99 40 جريمه منها 24
حاله اغتصاب همم بالاضافه الى عناصر اخرى
همم يعني ربما نتعرف عن تفاصيلها كان هناك
يجب تذكير ايضا بان كان هناك تقييم همم
لهذا الجهاز
العام الماضي وكان يعني سلبي للغايه بسبب
الاخفاقات حتى من قبل اولئك الذين لهم
انتماءات عنصريه كان هناك مثلا فئه معينه
من الضباط كانوا يتبادلون صور ل- اا ضحايا
وجثث همم
عبر تطبيق واتساب تم ادانه همم هذه
التصرفات من قبل هؤلاء همم الضباط
وبالتالي العمليه ستستمر ربما ستؤخذ بعض
الوقت لان نعيد هذه المنظمه الامنيه همم
استمعتها كما كانت من قبل شكرا لك يا
مصطفى
[موسيقى]
شدد الرئيس الامريكي
بامن وسلامه الامارات وشعبها في ذكرى
الاولى لهجوم ارهابي نفذته مليشيا الحوثي
على مواقع مدنيه في الامارات راحه ضحيته
ثلاثه مدنيين ابرياء واكد بادن في بيان
اصدره البيت الابيض على دعم الولايات
المتحده لدوله الامارات ضد اي تهديدات
سواء كانت من اليمن او من اي مكان اخر
مذكرا بثبات موقف بلاده زاء الحرب في
اليمن الرامي لانهاء الحرب بشكل سلمي وعبر
القنوات الديبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
تركت جامعه ترامب الزوجه السابقه للرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب تركت وراءها
ثلاثه اطفال
واربعه وثلاثين مليون دولار مقسمه بين عده
اصول وكلبا بعد وفاتها في يوليو الماضي
وفق مجله فورمز التي كشفت ان الثروه ستقسم
بين اطفال ايفانا كما تركت عقارين لاصدقاء
لها وحاول ترك عقار اخر لزوجها السابق
لكنه توفيق قبلها لم يحصل الرئيس الامريكي
الذي شارك في تشييعها على شيء من التركه
وتقول فورد ان ابرز الاصول في ملكيه
ايفانا هو منزل مستقل في مدينه نيويورك
يقع على بعد نصف مربع سكني من سنتر ويحاول
ورثتها حاليا بيعه ويطالبون ب 26.5 مليون
دولار ثمنا له هذا وتركت ايفانا ايضا
بحسبورد جميع ملابس على الصليب الاحمر
الامريكي مع استثناء الملابس المصنوعه من
الفاروق التي نشاهد ببيعها مع هابدا
العائدات الى اطفالها الثلاثه
[موسيقى]
الى البرازيل حيث اعفى الرئيس البرازيلي
لولا دا سيلفا 40 من العسكريين العاملين
في القصر الرئاسي بعد تعاهده اجراء مراجعه
شامله لتقم الامن جاء ذلك القرار في اعقاب
اعمال الشغالات شهدتها العاصمه البرازيليه
في الثامن من يناير الجاري واقتحام مقر
رئاسه والكونغرس والمحكمه العليا من جانب
انصار الرئيس السابق
بعد اسبوعين من تنصيب
هذا واظهرت مشاهدينا مقاطع مصوره للرئيس
البرازيلي السابق
جياربلسونارو اثناء تجوله في ولايه
فلوريدا الامريكيه التي فر اليها بعد
خسارته في الانتخابات وعبر بولسونارو في
تسجيل المصور عن اسفه لاحداث الشغب ضد
المؤسسات الحكوميه في برازيليا مشيرا الى
انه لم يحد عن المبادئ الدستوريه وضمان
الحريات ويذكر كان انتقل الى هناك قبل
يومين من تنصيب دا سيلفا في الاول من
يناير رافضا تسليب الوشاح الرئاسي الى
خصمه الذي هزمه بفارق بسيط في الانتخابات
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
[موسيقى]
دبابات
حتى النصر
[موسيقى]
يوسف
اخبار العربيه مستمره كما كل ليله والان
الى 360 مع زملاء راويه وطاهر راويه وطاهر
مساء الخير وماذا لديكم مساء النور
الدبابات الغربيه ودورها بمعركه الشرق
بالايام القادمه وايضا تقرير يرصد الاخطاء
بتعامل السياسه الامريكيه بملف المسيارات
الايراني
عدد سكان وحلم زعامه اقتصاد العالم مهدد
دفاتر
[ضحك]